المحقق والخبير الامريكي ستيفن باك هو
الرجل الذي تولى مهمه تحليل المقاطع
الصوتيه لحادثه اغتيال الزميله شيرين ابو
عاقله
لمكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي اف بي اي في
مقابلته الخاصه مع برنامج الجزيره التحقيق
ما خفي اعظم نتائج تحليلاته التي حسمت
الجدل حول مطلق النار الذي استهدف الزميله
شيرين في جنين
وفقا لحسابات فقد كان مطلق النار على بعد
ما بين 180 مترا الى 200 متر واكتشفنا
ايضا ان هناك مجموعه من جنود جيش الدفاع
الاسرائيلي كانوا على بعد 200 متر من ذلك
التقاطع حيث كانت الصحفيه والمصور لذا فان
بصمه الصوت تتطابق مع المسافه وتلك
الرصاصات كانت تتجه نحو الصحفي وعليه
اعتقد جازما ان ذلك يدعم حقيقه مفادها ان
اطلاق النار جاء من جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي
مصدر رفيع المستوى اطلع على الاتصالات بين
المسؤولين الامريكيين والاسرائيليين كشف
لما خفي اعظم ان مسؤولا اسرائيليا كبيرا
في مكتب وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي السابق
بنجانس اعترف بما لا يضع مجالا للشك
لمسؤولين امريكيين ان الرصاصه التي قتلت
الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله هي رصاصه
اسرائيليه وانها كانت نتيجه خطا لكنه اصر
على ان اسرائيل لن تعترف وتعلن ذلك رسميا
تحقيق ما خفي اعظم الذي حمل عنوان قتل
الادله عرض وثائق من التحقيقات
الاسرائيليه التي وثقت عمليات التلاعب
الممنهج بقضايا قتل واستهداف الصحفيين في
فلسطين على يد جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
والتهرب من المسؤوليه والعقاب الشهيدان
الصحفيان فضل شناعه وياسر مرتجى من غزه
والشهيد الصحفي نزيه دروزه من نابلس وثق
ما خفي اعظم كيف تم اقفال ملفات قتلهم
اثناء تغطياتهم الاعلاميه دون محاسبه
وايضا اخفاء ادله اغتيالهم كما وثق
التحقيق بالوثائق معاناه الصحفي معاذ
عمارنه الذي فقد عينه برصاصه جندي
اسرائيلي وما زال شاهدا على تبرئه الجنود
من اي مسؤوليه او عقاب في قضيه قتل اخرى
للصحفي البريطاني جيمس ميلر في رفح عام
ذهبت الحكومه الاسرائيليه الى دفع تعويض
مالي كبير للعائله
على وقع ضغط من الحكومه البريطانيه في
مشهد يظهر ازدواجيه المعايير
للجنايات الدوليه بحثا عن مقابله حول مصير
قضايا قتل الصحفيين في فلسطين فجاء الرد
لن نستطيع اجراء مقابله بهذا الخصوص